[Music]
hey hey oh how you guys doing mister
what's up buddy Tony Tony nice to meet
you Jamie Jamie
very nice to meet you James
oh there's a lot of history behind the
banjos a lot of history what we have
here is we have two of only 11 Dearing
commemorative SiC was censored
sesquicentennial the sick was censored
sit
Cisco centennial successful centennial
banjos that celebrated 150 years since
Texas's independence from Mexico in 1985
there was a lot of advertising for the
Texas sesquicentennial coming up in 1986
and I had this idea to design a banjo to
commemorate the sesquicentennial so I
sent the sketches to Greg Dearing as he
said yeah we want to make it this is the
prototype this is the first one and this
is the eleventh one now is there any
reason you've only sold 11 as it is
other harder you know they're 20 nearly
$22,000 oh yeah that's why that's why
the history is is that there are 50
states we here in Texas celebrate our
Centennial from the day we defeated
Santa Ana at San Jacinto which was April
21st 1836 Tony you do you know real
Google well yeah you said about 20 20 to
25,000 to get your hands on one up well
today the current price if you custom
ordered it would be about 22,000 or
sales tax
what's the CEO take down here it's a
point oh eight to five Oh Tony you sure
man I don't know about that Tim it lists
something that do you actually know how
to play it
do you like me to play something yes
[Music]
let me see the bottom wear your shoes
double tap how long have you been doing
that good thank you Tony
yes you go come on back you can't sneak
away with them damn shoes can I show you
something show me something the names
around the side yeah yeah that's Houston
fan in my lab rocket boy and Austin that
sounded like places in Texas
all of the men who's named around the
side they came from other places to help
us become the Republic and Mirabeau be
Lamar was from Georgia really yeah tell
me more tell me more about the
Republican Party well no it's not the
Republican Party it's the Republic of
Texas we became the 28th state in 1845
you know do you the real Texas Google so
talk to me about this last little piece
of art you got going down right here
well there's the state this is the
cowboy boot this colt 45 years to spur
the Lone Star cowboy hat long horn small
lariat in there and flags with
color-correct an unusual red it's red
185 I wanted a cowboy rope my Berthier
is on the back of this one Battle of the
Alamo and spatty up oh man so it's safe
to say you you like Texas a little bit
well yeah I like that so today we learn
how to black folk called the tap band
which I call it clogging thank you for
clogging I'm gonna talk to Tony for a
minute Tony man how you playing man it's
in an open G card family was expensive
banjo in the world
[Music]
[Music]
this is fun I told you I'm ready
wake snake day is breaking beans and
potting hoecakes making a bad chicken
fried turkey come over baby work me you
know I'm doing finger on this trial and
playing the banjo
[Music]
[Laughter]